مرحباً، اسمي ديفيد براون، وهذا درسٌ في القراءة والكتابة.
أهلاً، مرحباً بك. كيف حالُكَ؟
أهلاً، سررتُ بلقائك.
وأنا أيضاً سررتُ بلقائك. اسمي ديفيد. ما اسمُكَ؟
اسمي فرانشيسكو. من دواعي سروري أن ألتقي بك يا ديفيد.
سررتُ بلقائك يا فرانشيسكو. أهلاً بك.
أرى أنك اخترت درساً عن والت ويتمان وقصيدته الشهيرة،
"أوه، أيها القبطان، يا قبطاني!"، وهو درسٌ في القراءة والكتابة. هل هذا صحيح؟
نعم، هذا صحيح.
حسناً، عظيم.
إذاً، سأحدثك قليلاً عن أبراهام لينكولن.
ربما سمعت عن "آيب النزيه" من قبل، لقد كان الرئيس السادس عشر للولايات المتحدة.
لقد اغتيل عام 1865.
قد تقارنه بزعيم شهير آخر. هل تعرف من هذا الرجل؟
نعم، فرانشيسكو مورازان.
فرانشيسكو مورازان. حسناً، إنهما مختلفان، لكنهما رئيسان يتمتعان بشعبية كبيرة، أليس كذلك؟
صحيح. نعم.
إذاً السؤال المطروح علينا هو: ما الذي يجعل القائد جيداً؟
خذ دقيقة للتفكير في الأمر، ثم يمكنك أن تشاركني رأيك ونتحدث عن هذا.
ما الذي يجعل القائد جيداً في رأيك؟
حسناً.
هل تريدني أن أكتبه أم يمكنني أن أبدأ مباشرة؟
نعم، يمكنك ذلك.
أعتقد أنه ليس فقط شخصٌ يُلهم، بل يعرف أيضاً متى يتخذ إجراءً.
حسناً.
حسناً، أتفق معك. شخص لديه روح المبادرة، صحيح؟
نعم، بالتأكيد.
أعتقد أن كلا هذين القائدين كانا قائدين ألهما الآخرين واتخذا مبادرة عظيمة.
أتفق مع ذلك.
كلاهما شارك في بعض الإصلاحات الليبرالية الكبرى أيضاً.
حسناً، إذاً لدينا قائمة بأشياء يمكن أن تساعدنا على تحسين لغتنا الإنجليزية، وخاصة في القراءة والكتابة وكذلك المحادثة، حيث سنجري محادثة طوال الدرس بأكمله.
هذه هي أهداف درسنا.
هل يمكنك أن تقرأ أهداف الدرس بدءاً من هذا الهدف هنا؟
نعم، تحديد وشرح السياق التاريخي لقصيدة "أوه، أيها القبطان، يا قبطاني!".
تعريف المفردات الرئيسية.
على سبيل المثال،
مرثية،
عارضة السفينة، محنة،
أم أنها
مرثية.
وتحديد الاستعارة الممتدة في القصيدة.
تحليل الاستعارة الممتدة، وشرح ما يمثله القبطان، والسفينة، والرحلة المخيفة، والجائزة.
مناقشة نبرة القصيدة من حيث صلتها بالحزن والإعجاب.
والتعبير عن فهم القصيدة من خلال المناقشة والإجابات المكتوبة.
حسناً.
أوه، وربط موضوعات القصيدة عن الفقدان، والقيادة، والاستراتيجية الوطنية بمفاهيم أوسع للحرية.
هل هي حرية؟
مثل الحرية.
نعم.
آه، مثل الحرية.
حسناً، إذاً لدينا الكثير لنقوم به.
قد لا يكون لدينا وقت للقيام بكل هذا، ولكن بالتأكيد هناك الكثير لنتعمق فيه بخصوص هذه القصيدة.
وبالطبع، والت ويتمان والسياق التاريخي هنا.
يمكن أن تكون المفردات قديمة نوعاً ما لأنها كُتبت عام 1865 مباشرة بعد اغتيال أبراهام لينكولن.
لذا أريدك فقط أن تضع ذلك في اعتبارك ونحن نقرأ هذا.
لهذه القصيدة سياق.
وربما تتحدث عن شيء أعمق قليلاً.
فعندما نقول استعارة ممتدة، كما تعلم، الاستعارة هي عندما يكون "أ" هو "ب".
لكن الاستعارة الممتدة هي عندما تكون فقرة كاملة أو نص كامل يرمز إلى شيء ما.
حسناً.
إذاً، إليك بعض السياق التاريخي.
ولكن أولاً هنا، ماذا تعرف عن الحرب الأهلية الأمريكية أو أبراهام لينكولن؟
أوه، أعرف، أعرف لقب "آيب النزيه".
الحرب الأهلية الأمريكية كانت تتعلق تحديداً بالعبودية.
إن لم أكن مخطئاً، صحيح؟
نعم.
الشمال والجنوب.
ثم أبراهام لينكولن.
حسناً، لقد قلت الرئيس السادس عشر، لكن أعتقد أن هناك شيئاً ما.
أعتقد أنه اتخذ قراراً مهماً جداً ولا أتذكره تماماً.
شيء يُعرف به حقاً.
إعلان تحرير العبيد.
نعم.
حسناً.
ممتاز.
إذاً أنت تعرف بعض الشيء عن الحرب الأهلية الأمريكية في سياق هذه القصيدة.
كم كانت هذه الحرب الأهلية مهمة في الولايات المتحدة.
لم تؤثر فقط على الولايات المتحدة، بل كان لها تأثير متتالٍ على دول أخرى.
وغيرت الكثير من المواقف حقاً.
ولم ينتهِ الأمر بنهاية الحرب الأهلية.
وما زال الأمر لم ينتهِ.
حقاً، ما زلنا نكافح ضد عدم المساواة.
ما زلنا نكافح القضايا المتعلقة بالعبودية حول العالم.
وهذا السؤال حول ماذا يعني حقاً أن تكون حراً.
وما زالت معركة شاقة.
لذلك كتب والت ويتمان "أوه، أيها القبطان، يا قبطاني!" عام 1865 بعد وقت قصير من حدثين رئيسيين هنا.
هل يمكنك أن تقرأ لنا هذا الجزء؟
بالطبع، نهاية الحرب الأهلية، التي استمرت من 1861 إلى 1865.
صراع وحشي قسّم الأمة.
واغتيال الرئيس أبراهام لينكولن في أبريل 1865 بعد أيام قليلة فقط من استسلام الكونفدراليين.
اعتبر الكثيرون لينكولن القبطان الذي وجه دفة الأمة.
السفينة... عبر رحلة الحرب المخيفة.
إذاً نرى بالفعل مثالاً على الاستعارة: الأمة كسفينة، وهو من قادها، لقد كان القبطان.
في هذه القصيدة التي سنقرأها.
وهنا لدينا صورة ملونة أخرى لأبراهام لينكولن.
أعتقد أنه من الرائع أنهم يستطيعون الآن تلوين الصور القديمة.
ويجعلها تبدو حقيقية.
ومشهد مما كنتم سترونه في الصحف.
إذاً، كان أبراهام لينكولن في مسرح عندما أُطلق عليه النار واغتيل.
حسناً.
إذاً هنا لدينا بعض المصطلحات التي نحتاج إلى معرفتها.
وقد تتردد في بعض هذه المفردات.
إنها صعبة بعض الشيء.
لدينا الشعر الغنائي، المرثية، الاستعارة، والاستعارة الممتدة.
الشعر الغنائي هو شعر يعبر عن عواطف أو مشاعر شخصية.
وعادةً ما يُروى بضمير المتكلم.
فالقصيدة التي نحن على وشك قراءتها هي شعر غنائي.
وهذه، تذكر النطق، مرثية، هل يمكنك أن تقرأ لنا هذا؟
نعم.
قصيدة تأمل جاد، وعادة ما تكون رثاءً للموتى.
"أوه، أيها القبطان، يا قبطاني!" هي مرثية لأبراهام لينكولن.
حسناً.
إذاً نحن نتحدث عن شخص ما، قبطان قُتل.
وبالتالي فالقصيدة عميقة حقاً.
وقاتمة بعض الشيء بهذا المعنى.
عليك أن تتخيل الشعور في نهاية الحرب.
الشعور في نهاية الحرب هو شعور بالارتياح.
كما يمكنك أن تتخيل، ولكن أيضاً حزن عميق.
لا يمكنك استعادة الأرواح التي فُقدت.
لا يمكنك إلغاء ما حدث.
ما حدث قد حدث.
لدينا الاستعارة، وهي صورة بلاغية يُطبق فيها كلمة أو عبارة.
فعندما يكون شيء ما شيئاً آخر، ثم هذا امتداد لذلك، الاستعارة الممتدة.
هل يمكنك أن تقرأ لنا هذا؟
نعم.
استعارة تتطور عبر عدة أسطر من الكتابة أو حتى عبر عمل كامل.
ممتاز.
إذاً هذه هي القراءة الأولى.
سأقرأ لك هذا الجزء الأول.
أريدك أن تستمع إلى كيف يبدو هذا في النطق.
بينما تتبع العيون اليقظة والعارضة الثابتة.
السفينة الصارمة والجريئة.
ولكن آه، يا قلبي، يا قلبي، يا قلبي!
آه، قطرات الدم الحمراء النازفة!
حيث على السطح، يرقد قبطاني، سقط بارداً وميتاً.
إذاً لدينا هذه الصورة لسفينة ذات عارضة.
إذاً جزء معين من السفينة، صحيح؟
السفينة الصارمة والجريئة.
ترى هذه السفينة المظلمة تدخل.